Hong Kong security chief claims that
terrorism is on the rise in the city as
police arrest some 180 protesters during
renewed unrest thousands took to the
streets to protest Beijing's plans to
oppose a security law on that former
British colony it would bypass the local
legislature and is expected to ban what
China calls treason and Sedition
pro-democracy campaigners say it is a
threat to Hong Kong's freedoms and
semi-autonomy I go now to the senior
reporter Laura Westbrook from Hong Kong
newspaper the South China Morning Post
she has more on this story for us good
morning to you we've seen a quick and
heavy crackdown in Hong Kong is this a
sign of a new and tougher approach by
Beijing yes I think it is the protests
which have been going on since last year
have become increasingly more violent as
we saw yesterday and with slogans like
revolution of our times and calls for
Hong Kong independence by some of the
more radical protesters I think Beijing
is is saying that this is something that
it no longer is willing to tolerate and
it sees the Hong Kong protests as a
direct threat to national security over
the past few months Beijing has also
made accusations of foreign interference
in the protests
now the protesters deny this and Beijing
has not produced any evidence of outside
forces directing the protests on the
ground but I think it's also important
to look at these protests and Beijing's
approach in the context of its
relationship with the US which is soured
in because of the trade war and the
covert 19 pandemic last year the US
Congress passed the Hong Kong human
rights and democracy Act which mandates
an annual review on Hong Kong's autonomy
that gives it its special trading status
with the US and that review is coming up
and Hong and the US National Security
Advisor has said this law could warrant
sanctions in Hong Kong in China so I
think China is looking at Hong Kong as
increasing
a weak link in its national security
that could potentially be exploited by
the US okay still the protesters are
talking about local issues how are they
likely to respond and could we see a
return to the huge demonstrations of
last year yes I think it's important to
remember what sparked those protests
last year it was a now withdrawn
extradition bill that would have seen
pros of fugitives in Hong Kong sent to
mainland China to face trial there
now people saw that as a challenge to
Hong Kong's freeze ins that it enjoys
under one country two systems'
and this national security legislation
is also seen as a challenge to Hong
Kong's one country two systems'
principle that gives it freedom of
speech and the right to assembly and
those freedoms that you don't see on
mainland China and I think a lot of
people here are really worried that
those freedoms we will be eroded by this
new national security legislation and so
yes we're probably going to see more
protests as we saw yesterday briefly if
you could Alaura the law that we're
talking about would give China the power
to deploy security forces in Hong Kong
what is Beijing have in mind yeah a lot
of things still need to be ironed out
but one of the proposals that has been
announced is that the mainland codes
have agencies in Hong Kong and
potentially mainland agents operates in
Hong Kong enforcing this new national
security legislation now the Hong Kong
government is said they would still be
subject to local law but many people
have questioned how that would work and
obviously it's got some people in Hong
Kong quite worried because mainly the
mainland China does use national
security legislation to go after
journalists activists and even lawyers
so that announcement has got some people
worried about how exactly that will work
given Hong Kong's law structure in Hong
Kong's system Laura Westbrook for us
from the South China Morning Post thanks
so much for coming in on this
markets in Hong Kong fell right after
this weekend's protests over that
proposed national security bill for the
former British colony here's more Hong
Kong's Hang Seng stock index fell one
percent on Monday after police used tear
gas to quell weekend protests over a
controversial national security bill
gloom prevailed as US China tensions
ratcheted up and China's yuan currency
lost value and market players believe
this could only be the beginning how
economies been on the rebound in May
because their success in containing the
co 890 virus but this will all be
damaged by the national security law and
and it depends on how the government
control managed control the riots if the
government XA I insist hell and jail as
many protesters as possible then the
protest will gradually window out
sentiment was also muted in the mainland
where the Shanghai Composite was largely
unchanged
most Asian forces were lifted by signs
the coronavirus lockdown is lifting the
Nikkei 225 and Tokyo rose 1.5 percent
and South Korea's kospi index gained
nearly 1 percent